-Well, guys, it is Week 6
of the NFL season...
[ Laughter ]
...and this Sunday night's game
features the Seattle Seahawks
facing off
against the Pittsburgh Steelers.
-Ooh.
-Now, as you know,
at the end of every season,
they give out awards
like Most Valuable Player,
but they also give out awards
during the season.
I'll show you what I mean.
It's time for
"'Tonight Show' Superlatives."
Here we go.
-♪ "Tonight Show" Superlatives ♪
♪♪
-The first player
is from the Seahawks.
This is Colby Parkinson.
He was voted...
[ Applause ]
"Costa's the bomb, dude."
This next one from the Steelers
is B.J. Finney.
He was voted...
[ Laughter and applause ]
Next up from the Seahawks
is Dakoda Shepley.
He was voted...
-Really?
Wow, that's an award?
-Yeah, it's a rare award.
They rarely give it out.
Next up from the Steelers
is Derrek Tuszka.
He was voted...
[ Laughter and applause ]
Next up from the Seahawks
is Jamarco Jones.
He was voted...
"You gotta be kidding.
Gotta be joking."
Next up from the Seahawks
is Cody Barton.
He was voted...
[ Laughter and applause ]
-Teeths?
-Teeths.
Next up from the Seahawks
is Will Dissly.
He was voted...
[ Laughter and applause ]
Next up from the Seahawks
is Jake Curhan.
He was voted...
And finally, from the Seahawks
is D.K. Metcalf.
He was voted...
There you have it, everybody.
Those are your superlatives.